madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre
madame la ministre messieurs les
ministres mesdames les ministres pardon
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
le premier qui se réveille
les autres
disent les enfants
les premiers à être réveillés
ont été les Ukrainiens
ils savaient depuis longtemps en tout
cas depuis 2014 ce que nous voulions
ignorer depuis plus longtemps encore
à savoir que les puissances occidentales
n'avaient pas vraiment gagné la guerre
froide même si l'Union soviétique
l'avait clairement perdu nos amis nos
frères du Crès ont éprouvé dans leur
cœur et dans leur chair ce que nous
avons longtemps
obstinément
inconsidémie inconsidérément refusé de
voir nos triomphes apparents des années
90 n'avait assuré durablement et
universellement ni la souveraineté des
peuples ni la démocratisation des états
ni la liberté des consciences des
opinions et des mouvements l'invasion
arbitraire injustifiée et terriblement
meurtrière de la libre crène par une
puissance impérialiste et cleptocratique
la tragiquement montrée
aujourd'hui les souffrances et les
victoires de l'Ukraine nous confirment
dans une conviction que les Français ont
été trop longtemps les seuls à professer
dans l'Union européenne cette conviction
c'est celle qui veut que l'Europe ces
valeurs ses intérêts sa culture et ses
lois ne pourront survivre dans le monde
qui nous attend si les européens
continuent de faire de leur union une
entité simultanément marchande et
éthérés naïve Adil président de la
République étrangère en toute état cause
à toute logique de puissance nous autres
Français avons de longues dates pensées
que l'universalisme de nos valeurs ne
pouvaient nous dispenser de l'obligation
d'inscrire notre projet dans un
territoire particulier fragile et
menacée ce petit cap de l'Asie décrit
par Paul Valéry et que personne
défendra durablement s'il ne se défend
pas lui-même nous avons passionnément
voulu donner une dimension géopolitique
au projet européen ajoutez la force au
droit la réciprocité à l'exemplarité les
intérêts aux valeurs l'ambition à
lapostolat la défense et la division
d'une culture à la défense de
l'humanisme les
Ukrainiens nous ont réveillé ils nous
ont dit par l'invasion qu'ils ont subi
par la résistance qui lui ont opposé par
les souffrances assumées par les deuils
accumulés où est notre devoir ce qu'est
notre mission quelles sont nos
responsabilités en défendant sa
souveraineté ces libertés sa démocratie
l'Ukraine défauts notre souveraineté nos
libertés nos démocraties on est dans
l'Ukraine à se défendre les Ukrainiens
défendent l'Europe nous avons pu mesurer
aux côtés de la présidente de notre
assemblée la détermination du président
zzky et derrière lui celle de tout un
peuple un peuple inventif mobilisé
actifs et entreprenant un peuple
impavide devant les provocations les
référendums bidons les mascarades
cérémoniales qui vise au sublime et une
rencontre que le grotesque nous devons
mes chers collègues être à la hauteur
des responsabilités que nous impose la
situation nous sommes à la veille de
grandes épreuves elles imposent et
sacrifices aux Ukrainiens les Russes ont
pas besoin de recourir à l'arbre
nucléaire pour nous atteindre dans notre
confort et dans notre relatif quiétude à
nous non plus on ne sort pas vainqueur
d'une telle épreuve sans force d'âme
sans énergie sans rejet des divisions
bien sûr nous avons aussi un devoir de
sagesse le souci d'éviter la
généralisation de la guerre le dérapage
vers les armes de destruction massive la
préservation des chances de la paix le
monde peut monter sur nous pour
travailler dès que ce sera possible et
avec qui ce sera possible au
rétablissement de la paix mais l'issue
du conflit passera par le respect
scrupuleux de la souveraineté de
l'Ukraine l'établissement de garantie de
sécurité sérieuse et crédible et la
reconstruction d'un pays martyr
aujourd'hui l'heure est à la solidarité
inconditionnelle avec le peuple
ukrainien et que serait notre solidarité
sinon une abject hypocrisie si nous
n'apportuntion pas aux Ukrainiens les
moyens de se défendre et de vivre il n'y
a pas d'amour sans preuve d'amour il n'y
a pas de solidarité sans preuve de
solidarité l'Europe et pour la première
fois depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale confrontée à une responsabilité
historique majeure ensemble relevons ce
grand défi il en va de notre avenir à
tous que vivent l'Ukraine que vive la
France que vive l'Europe
[Applaudissements]